my name is pewdiepie and i [ __ ] in the
shower once
how's it going bros today we're checking
out strangers
sharing their secret anonymously what
other secrets do people have
it's my time to judge you for your
secrets
because i shared mine and everyone made
fun of me set up a microphone in public
and asked strangers yes
i'll say they're allowed to show their
face okay
walk away unknown
i increased my antidepressant meds
the other day and i was not ready for
the side effects
so while i was vacuuming i [ __ ] my pants
uh
well she show her face that's the entire
thing
she walks away well there we go i feel
less bad now
i'm not the only one with that or a
little hearse was a bit
probably more valid i was poisoned okay
you're browsing the internet unsecurely
nor the vpn bonus say it with me
i got you the deal of century you get a
huge discount on a two-year plan with a
bonus
of one to four additional months for
free but felix what this vpn vpn helps
you securely browse the internet now
with strict no logs policy
it's out of their business basically
nothing will be tracked and collected
and you can do whatever you want baby
it's all right you can tell me it helps
you stay safe not just for your own
internet but also if you're browsing a
public wi-fi it's pretty much a standard
way to protect yourself from people
snooping and stealing your passwords and
private information which can easily be
done otherwise
norvpn is also available on your phone
if you connect a public wi-fi with that
or anything else
but also one of the greatest things
about nordvpn is that you can browse
anywhere in the world
watch and download and get the most out
of your subscription services with
different kind of shows
it's just super handy to have when you
need it i was always that time when oh
let's watch that show oh it's not out
here yet
yeah skip all that baby you're done and
i also think it's important to have a
wide and open internet so
thank you nordvpn for making that
possible they also have a nord pass
which is a password manager
that helps you store all your passwords
safely and also make better passwords
highly recommend that as well so yeah
take control of your internet again with
nordvpn and get an additional bonus
for free nordvpn.com pewdiepie enter
code pewdiepie
you are welcome get a huge discount you
are welcome
now let's get on with the video so right
now i'm
leading on two people separately
one guy one girl man you need a haircut
you gotta trim the sides bro
cause i'm bi like that and i didn't mean
to do that but now i
am and i've told each of them that i'm
not really talking to anyone else
so i have to figure out a way to resolve
that and go with one of them
kind of sucks but price you pay for
leaving people on i guess
um is he wearing a
fanny pack man's got a fanny pack and
gets
two with that haircut too i don't
understand anymore i understand nothing
well at least he admitted it he knows
it's bad i thought about lying at work
and saying my dad is dead just so i can
get a couple of days off
he's alive i just really he's not in my
life and i
can't stand him just kind of want a
couple of stick days
damn like a lot of people do this they
don't like their dad and they just say
he's dead and everyone goes whoa
but they're thinking inside to me idiots
give me time off work now at least she
didn't do it she saw it
she said she's thinking about it it's
okay you gotta pass
i have lost over 140 pounds and whenever
anyone asks me how i did it i say hard
work but in reality i had a gastric
sleeve surgery to help me
it's kind of funny it's kind of funny
though oh no i just worked really hard
i feel like a lot of people do that
don't they you wouldn't say that you
just worked hard you'd be like you know
you know diet he's got diet bro
when i was in high school me and my
friends would
go run around and hang out down in
sewers and big culverts oh god did
someone die
and we called ourselves the sewer boys
we would crawl
out from the drainage pipes and just
end up being really stinky all the time
that's it that's just he walks away
stinky sewage boy walks away his secret
identity never will be revealed
sewage boys what
i need to know more you can't just
drop the fact like that i got it over my
sous voice
come on so i'd have to say my biggest
secret would be
the fact that i'm 25 years old never
been kissed but i'm okay with it
[Music]
oh god watch all the sims in the
comments now
girl who's never been kissed is gorgeous
there's nothing wrong with
not kissing anyone it's more like oh
it's a secret all right sure
my friends and i when we graduated high
school we
all hopped in one of my one of my
friends comes from a really big family
so he's got this huge
van and i'm waiting for someone like and
then they all died
and i got away with it something crazy
so far the best one is sewage boys all
got in the van and drove down this
really busy road down in arizona where
we're from
and then why and played the yellow light
game
what is that it's just a bunch of like
10 dudes in the car and we all played
any yellow light you saw we had to touch
the roof and the last one to touch the
roof had to
take an item of clothing off we all got
nearly naked it was just
really stupid and funny because the car
got super
steamy and gross but it was a fun time
and a memory that i'll probably never
forget
what you don't even show yourself
i didn't shower for you do you
understand what the hell
kind of team i could share like at least
in another 10
shower stories i've just learned my
lesson not to do that
what is days what is this you had a
steamy car
right that's it i mean good for you what
get out of here watching these videos
about people in their secret remind me
that we are not
perfect what do you mean man just did
played strip poker
hi my secret is i farted in the sistine
chapel
holy you did not
oh he show himself the mask farter
or i've probably farted in every room
and i've ever been into we're like what
do you
what um
sometimes okay this might be good
i smell sharpies
everyone doesn't smell delicious don't
smell sharpies it's bad for brain don't
end up like me
so my secret is uh when i lived in l.a i
was taking a
a long run and i was outside like
running by
the airport and you saw someone get
murdered but you didn't call for help
on the sidewalk and i had ran like three
miles
out so i had to run three miles to get
back and i had to get really bad
so okay all right on the side of the
road
and used my sock to wipe my ass all
right hell yeah
you go girl you turn around and you be
proud
you gotta go you gotta go okay three
miles
you could hold it three miles she
basically said one time i took a [ __ ] in
the woods
congratulations okay talk to me when
you're
in the shower i secretly uh steal
ribeye steak from different
grocery stores around my
early 20s by hiding them under uh
water bottles so you put the steak down
he puts the water on top
they don't bother lifting it so that's
smart
anyone from our big conglomerates i okay
you're okay man really wanted his steak
too i respect that
[Music]
when i was young uh me and my friend
would go to different shops and we would
steal
uh portal magazines and then we hid them
in the woods and then my neighbor saw us
and he ratted me out for my mom and said
that we were hiding cigarettes but i was
like mom it's just porno mags
and then she just dropped the
conversation there and i don't
understand why
i've been really indecisive about my
major for the past
two years but i act like i'm really
passionate about it
[Music]
whoa that's hard he's not super sure
about
his major no one's ever gone through
that in their life i shut the shower how
many time i gotta say
huh to be a little rebellious i often
refuse to wear a seat belt
stop chuckle
let's go let's go oh i love that
that was great
it's so sweet so when i was 19
uh i stole my twin brother's identity
opened up a bank account just to cash
one of his old paychecks oh
hell yeah he was off at college well
that's
it what oh that's so good if you have a
twin you can just steal identity
genius so i'm a hairstylist
and i secretly hate when people open
their eyes and talk to me
okay i'm not a hairstylist and what do
people not shave these anymore
what is happening here in this video
while i wash their hair it's super
creepy
and i have a bad angle and it's just
a really intimate head massage between
two strangers
and worst case there will be open mouth
and moaning
and it's just not fun i want it to be
over but you want a longer massage
close your eyes bruh oh my god i'm glad
he said this
because i always find myself like okay
i'm getting a hair massage am i
supposed to like this i feel like a like
a robot or an alien i'm just like i
don't know
what to do i don't i literally don't go
to the hairdresser anymore mine's a
customer here because i find
everything related to a haircut so
uncomfortable from the small talk
to the washing of your hair do i keep my
eyes closed
it took me like 16 years to realize oh
i should probably close my eyes when
they do this am i i don't know
i don't know what to do and i understand
it feels good but i also
look what no i hate it
face base hairdresser well done i'm glad
he hates it too that makes me feel a
little better so i'm actually
more in love with my best friend um
he's a girl then my boyfriend of a year
she's my soul mate my life partner my
one true love
we started being best friends in college
and it just
escalated to bigger and better things
more
so a relationship and uh true spiritual
soulful connection than anyone else i've
ever
thought i've loved and even though i am
in a heteronormative relationship for
the sake of society and my parents
and uh what i thought i want out of life
girl you're just hurting the boyfriend
you're with your parents
society do what you want please this is
great
the channel is maraemer honesty check it
out
thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed smash like subscribe
and all that bitty boo buddy
see you tomorrow